[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour l excuse pour la coutume à
parler de tout oui et bien là la balle
je prends la boule verte ouf mais prend
tout ce que tu veux
j'en aurai d'autres toute façon chouette
hélène et cécile se sont rencontrés il y
a plus de dix ans grâce au sel touraine
un système qui permet d'échanger des
biens et des services contre une monnaie
virtuelle propres à chaque celle ici ce
sont des grains cantons ceux des objets
comme l' objet plante ses divers on est
venu pour une plante ce quinze grands
pour un jour lui donne rien j'ai rien à
lui est donnée aujourd'hui par contre je
peux donner autre chose à quelqu'un un
autre jour au sel touraine chaque
échange est consigné dans un petit
carnet
on a une
un code par exemple 700 c'est catherine
qui m'avait aidé pour l'ordinateur trois
ans et polk
il y avait la garde des chiens de paul
nahon fait c'est ce qui revient plus
souvent chez moi c'est les choses au
jardin oui
la seule règle ne pas dépasser les 3000
grain que ce soit en tant qu offreurs ou
en tant que receveur histoire
d'équilibrer les échanges on fait aussi
des des blés les blés ça veut dire
bourse locale d'échangé
ça fait comme une petite brocante et
entre nous bien sûr alors et sans argent
alors moi j'ai plein de choses à la
maison que je prie que ce soit des
cadres que ce soit des du linge par
exemple du linge de des draps de la
vaisselle tout c'est super comme ça ça
permet aux gens dans une mare entière
j'en ai marre de cet objet je me mets là
et moi il me plaît justement est aussi
se fait de recyclage et sa faible depuis
le début de l'épidémie les bosses local
des changes ont été suspendus ces ses
listes ceux qui adhèrent à ce système en
ont improvisé une petite dans les
jardins ouvriers de tours-nord une
tunique assez large
y'a une une veste la demande enfance
enfin non là c'est adultes plutôt et là
c'est à doha dont quatre ans à 35
il faut marchand l'intérêt c'est quand
même de rendre service aux gens
de se rendre service d'éviter de mettre
des objets à la poubelle
voilà c'est aussi écologique mais c'est
aussi sociale si vous voulez parce que
les gens peuvent
et puis c'est aussi conviviale parce que
c'est une rencontre entre les gens d
amitié très forte pas vrai coup de moi
j'ai trouvé que ça ça pourrait être
intéressant pour ma petite fille
on peut discuter avec des gens
d'horizons divers qui ont fait des
choses vraiment différentes mais qui ont
cet esprit
voilà dead d'entre elles de solidarité
dans les selles il ya aussi des gens qui
ont des petits moyens et par exemple
quand on a nos bourses locales des
changes les blés il y en a qui vont
trouver une paire de chaussures ou un
manteau qui n'auraient pas pu s'acheter
les gens ne se sentent pas de vol
puisque chacun donne quand il est prêt
et selon ce qu'il a donc celle qui
revient avec ses trois salades ou sa
paire de chaussures
et bien c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
lui a donné elle l'a mérité si vous
voulez elle a choisi le s'il a choisi
les systèmes d'échangés locaux d'indre
et loire compte une centaine d'adhérents
en plus des biens laissés listes peuvent
offrir ou demander des services qu'il
évalue en temps passé
direction chaumont sur loire dans le
loir et cher
anne et ses listes depuis 25 ans
passionné de permaculture
elle a un grand jardin de 1600 mètres
carrés elle a besoin d' aide pour
planter des arbres elle a demandé
l'intervention de deux ses listes de
blois qu'elle connaît bien
[Musique]
ils doivent d'être transporté le compost
ça c'est bien
ils vont mélanger l'apport que je vais
donner à l'arbre pour alléger cette
terre
et tout ça c'est de la physique j'ai
tout mais à petite allure et avec moi de
joie
s'il n'ya pas de temps en temps
quelqu'un qui vient ne donna cumin et
qui ont progressé dans les selistes
confrères sont lilas aides soignantes et
denis demandeurs d'emploi c'est le
principe même de l' échange de services
dans la gratuité
donc je veux dire je pense qu'il ya
toujours des gens qui ont des besoins
bien précis et puis ben justement je
pense que quand on on est dans une phase
où on est inactif on reste dans
l'activité et puis ça permettrait du
lien quoi donc c'est toujours important
je pense à des relations humaines
ça fait du bien au moral c'est retrouver
les vraies valeurs du partage qui existe
qui existait déjà autrefois et qui sont
un petit peu oubliée de nos jours il
n'ya jamais rien sans rien alors qu'avec
le sel c'est vraiment un échange des
échanges que ce soit intellectuel manuel
garate riels le don de soi aussi
on a tous besoin des uns des autres pour
tous et surtout en ce moment
lila et denis donnent plus qu'ils ne
reçoivent un peu comme christian réputé
meilleur bricoleurs du sel de blois il
intervient sept à huit fois par mois
chez dc liste pour des petites et
panache
j'ai toujours fait des pages à domicile
mais dont je suis la retraite je partais
de cette association
j'aime rencontrer les gens associés à ce
que j'aime faire c'est des choses qu'ils
maîtrisent ya peuvent pas faire ces
trous électricien pour changer une
ampoule vous ne trouverez pas on peut
pas nous dire qu'on pique la place des
artisans sursis simple que ça je te
remercie super pour moi c'est super mais
pour soi c'est simple mais pour moi
aussi autrefois
les selles existe en france depuis 25
ans la région centre val de loire est
une des moins bien pourvues elle en
compte une vingtaine à joué-lès-tours au
centre social une autre forme d'
échanges s'opèrent entre les habitants
lyon va devenir plus consistant presque
un petit peu quand on commence à faire
un caramel pour ça qu'il faut toujours
tourner tourner et veiller à un feu
bouillon pendant martina myard a créé le
réseau d'échangés réciproques des
savoirs dans le quartier de la vallée
violette pour rapprocher les gens notre
adn anosy et les échanges de savoirs
joffre à savoir ils demandent à savoir
et donc on fait circuler les savoirs
c'est vraiment notre adn dans les selles
par contre c'est plus des services
ils échangent dit fernand ou débit à
puce les offres et les demandes de
savoir peuvent être régulière ou
ponctuelle
les adhérents du réseau sont libres de
venir quand il le soit
dès qu'elle a pris sa retraite
christiane ancienne enseignante à
adhérer au réseau des petites violette
elle y a appris l'italien et la couture
et offert ses talents de cuisinière le
plus difficile c'est de savoir ce qu'on
a à offrir parce qu'on se connaît pas
bien passé bien que ça ou alors on croit
que ce qu'on sait ça sert pas ou feint
voilà et et puis si je me suis rendu
compte que je savais alors j'avais
appris bien des choses sur la cuisine
italienne maintenant je peux vous faire
un tiramisu je peux vous faire des
lasagnes je bouffe
voilà c'est genre de choses tu piques
ton aiguille n'y a pas de dents ah oui
voilà maintenant tu ton d'accord pour
être sûrs d'être tueur cuisine
informatique les savoirs échangés sont
très divers chacun peut 7 des
connaissances qu'il peut transmettre aux
autres il n'y a pas de grands ou de
petits savoir dans les réseaux
d'échangés réciproques de savoirs savoir
jouer un jeu où savoir parler une langue
ou maîtriser des logiciels etc ou une
recette de cuisine tout est au même
niveau
on part du principe qu'un savoir c'est
inestimable
c'est ce qui est plus important est la
valeur d'un savoir la seule valeur qui
corresponde c'est un autre savoir donc
ya pas besoin d'être ingénieur ou de
d'être professeur pouvoir transmettre
alors moi ce que je conseille c'est pas
mettre des branches trop
il faut mettre des fleurs aussi pour que
ça soit réglé non contrairement au sel
le ton des échanges des pas compter
l'important c'est que chacun vienne dans
le réseau avec une offre et une demande
de savoir
[Musique]
à saint cyr sur loire près de tours le
réseau les sentiers des savoirs organise
deux à trois échanges par semaine en
extérieur au programme de cet après midi
dont 100 lignes éducation canine et
lectures théâtralisées a nié sylvaine
pratique le théâtre depuis de nombreuses
années elle partage ici l'art expérience
on va prononcer des phrases un peu
compliqué sur le plan diction alors
angèle et gilles en gilet gel angèle et
fils en gilet gel angèle et gilles en
village elle j'aime tellement ça que je
me dis que les gens qui ont envie de le
faire bas c'est intéressant aussi
pouvoir partager avec eux ce savoir
eux-mêmes ont des idées ça se développe
la première année bombail faisais ce que
je leur disais de fer point final et
après ils ont émis eux mêmes des idées
pour les décors m'ont fait la mise en
scène de la pièce mais il me donne aussi
ils m'apportent leurs impressions leurs
idées et ça c'est très important
c'est très important de pouvoir échanger
là dessus on attend toujours des autres
alors qu'on peut très bien donner et
donner ça donne du plaisir quoi ça fait
du bien
c'est psychologiquement on se sent utile
on
et puis on partage le partage enfin
c'est génial le partage quoi les
vitamines habitude les oies pépites à
votre habitude prise en pitié ces piteux
le métier de mes pieds pepita
pourrais-tu de base est déjà savin la
solitude ça on évite beaucoup de
solitude on a beaucoup de gens qui sont
les sentiers des savoirs s'ennuyer chez
eux et dès qu'ils ont découvert
l'association sont se sont investis par
ce que parce que par plaisir et par
plaisir de rencontrer du monde et là on
va faire un arrêt de boue alcoa de bon
donc on dit de vous si le chien a
tendance à se rassoit instinctivement on
carrasso le ventre et qu'on a mis dans
ce chantage la danse
le vélo n'a prétendu que le jour ici
enfin pancol des choses ça consomme du
play on arrive ceux qui n'ont rien a
faire faut venir il faut pas hésiter
parce que ça y est on pioche et ce qui
nous pose ce qui nous plaît voilà bien
mais il vient vers moi non plus jean
barrull on y va au pied alors là j'ai un
chien que pas du tout à moi que je ne
connais pas c'est pas grave et on va
faire un demi-tour à droite je me
réalise
j'ai des projets parce que comme si
proche de la retraite et que j'ai arrêté
de travailler
ça me permet de me dire tiens c'est pas
la mort qui m'attend c'est des projets
ce sont des projets et en plus on
échange on c'est une famille les
sentiers des savoirs comme tout club 1 1
2 1 2 3 en retour
1 2 1 2
[Musique]
ce sont surtout des femmes de 55 à 65
ans qui adhèrent à ces réseaux des
changes
ils sont ouverts à tous mais ils ont du
mal à attirer les jeunes et les hommes
peut-être qu'après cette période
difficile
le besoin de contact humain bénéficiera
à ces réseaux réseaux ou échanger et
surtout un prétexte pour se rencontrer